what you guys take on Costco fruit I
think it's whack oh rotiss chicken for
$4.99 fruit oh fruits dude almost yeah
no no no I watermelon a good deal I to P
myself
in I got
[Music]
defens Hey Joe do you know about um the
Taiwanese uh tax receipt Lottery what is
this okay why would I know I didn't I
really expected that you would know it
seems like something would know he does
know a lot of facts you're Taiwanese
right that is something I would be
interested in though you're right by the
way if you guys ever have tax questions
he's really good that said so there's a
Trader on taiwan's mcoin Max crypto
exchange and he just made about
$310,000 American 10 million
NTD which I believe is um is a currency
NT yeah there's currency what is it
called NT is just called NT is it
abbreviation I don't know n
I don't know so he's a he's a crypto
Trader right so helpful he's he's on
there he's trading crypto and every time
he has um a trade he has to pay a tax on
that to the government to the government
right so he reports a a six cent trade
that he that he did right it's basically
like 6 cents is the the amount that he
owes in taxes so he reports like from
that trade it's a small amount of money
that he was trading right so then he
finds out and once he does that he's
entered into to their lottery for
reporting his his taxes because they
they reward people they reward people
they've had this program for for decades
now where they reward you for reporting
your taxes that's kind of Co you're
entered into a lottery when you report
your taxes and this guy won well how
much you made that's fun from a 6 Cent
transaction being honest how much did he
win
$310,000 Oh I thought he made that on on
crypto no dude that's actually a good
way to get people to pay their taxes no
don't get your help sub it's never going
to happen of course it won't that's so
cool that that makes people all report
their yeah taxes yeah it gives you an
incentive to like yeah cuz the
government gets to make a lot if you're
poor yeah it'll make you want to report
your taxes if you're rich you're still
going to be like it might be at a loss
that you won yeah it's all good Grand
yeah so it's basically just going to
further the
Divide so good said that well so
aggressive what a spokesman wow 300
Grand in Taiwan is like a million
dollars here oh yeah it's crazy no it's
it's it's actually a lot more because
this is a $2 tax for them that was 6
cents
us yeah yeah so the ratio is a lot more
it is yeah do the math I can't I just
know the uh taiwan's not a third world
country but the dollar goes very very
very far over there you could live third
world if you want oh really that's
what's dope about it like Taiwan like
you can't have they have like all the
regular stores that you see in America
right like [__] LV whatever mhm but
then if you want to live like the island
life my dad and buy your groceries from
the farmers market and all that like my
my uncle's a dentist there so he makes
like white collar money right but then
he buys all his [__] from the farmers
market swap meat even his slacks and all
that and he says his expenses for the
whole year was like 11,000 a whole year
car that's what my dad did that's a m
does he like Costco do they have Costco
they have Costco too but that to them
that's expensive Costco's expensive why
why would I do that if I could just go
to Farmers Market and buy a batch of
leaks for five nickels or whatever
theck farmers markets here are expensive
yeah farmer maret here are frauds have
you noticed that frauds yeah so a lot of
the a lot of the farmers markets are
just people buying uh cheap groceries
and just saying they're a farm do you
know how much you buy [__] these
these these cherries for the Rainer
cherries I've boughten a carton of
cherries for like $25 once just cuzz my
wife wanted I hate that man when my wife
wants and it's out of season
and I'm buying [__] grapes for $45
[__] ridiculous dude it's like they're
[__] grapes dude bubblegum grapes are
pretty good though they're very good
what's you guys take on Costco fruit I
think it's whack rotisserie chicken for
$4.99 fruit oh
fruits almost yeah no no no watermelon a
good deal I would to punch myself in
the I got
defensive I think their watermelon is a
good deal the problem is it good though
yeah oh really I haven't had the water
it depends which Costco you go to is
very good I think their fruits kind of
wack a Whack Attack kind of whack Whack
Attack you got to go to different you
got to go to eight different
supermarkets to get all your groceries
anyway I don't even like fruit they all
taste like [__] to me where do you get
your watermelon the famous Nick
watermelon that you love so much Costco
I get a Costco it's a good deal yeah uh
Trader Joe's I like it uh actually
Trader Joe's is pretty good how much is
okay how much is it you say it's a good
deal four times how much is it in Hawaii
it's like 10 but that's a good deal for
Hawaii 10's horrible but it's like 5 lb
it's like 20 if you if you go to regular
market right no it's noteven bucks I'm
saying relative to where you live so in
in Vegas it's like five bucks but in
Hawaii so it's like it's wherever you're
at it's the best deal okay yeah okay but
if you had a [__] Taiwanese Night
Market downstairs that shit's how much
is that five nickel five nickel five
nickels yeah that's his currency dude my
[__] my uncle he'll like like he has
to like look presentable right cuz he's
like seeing patience and [__] his dress
shirts are a dollar each damn like just
the type of life you can live is CRA
like you can if you were like a stock
broker but you just wanted to buy all
your [__] from like cuz it's like f
Taiwan is like a first and third world
country at the same time like
simultaneously you just call it second
world maybe second world one and a half
and you could just [__] cut him
suggesting it dude you could buy [__]
like beef noodle soup for [__] like
three cents and [__] it's [__] crazy
that's funny because I feel like our
impression of Taiwan looks like Hong
Kong to us where it's like looks
unlivable like it looks like so
expensive the prices are so like
skyrocketed in Tai yeah oh but that that
would be like my plan H like if [__]
[__] failed like in in in America I
don't know what the [__] to do what's
plan X do you are Republic of Congo no I
think plan H is is is already set I'll
I'll sell [__] a a thing of cocaine
make 5gs and then [__] go live there
forever five grab five grab it can go
far dude it's sell a thing have the
cocaine no we'd have to get it do you
have the plane yeah you got to get the
plane too does your uncle look like
Jackie Chan dude I was at I was in Bali
you're you know bali's sick right B's
sick I'm about to know tothy and it's
dude it was it was so cheap there it was
insane like we're going to like these
like five star places and it's like so
cheap and [__] it's like for getting a
drink oh like like 150 bucks like to
stay there for like two days or whatever
two days like a nice Villa and we kept
on going to different Villas cuz like
there's so bless bless you sir but we're
there and I'm there with like my buddy
and his chick at the time and like um me
and Nikki are just buying like $5 drinks
at the at the hotel and then he just
disappears and I'm like where the [__]
did he go and apparently he wanted to
save even more money so he goes to like
one of those like little um outlet malls
and he buys like a thing of vodka and
orange soda for like cheap but and he's
like making that to have in the room no
but he's hanging out at the [__]
market so he's we came to Bali we're
standing at this F star resort and [__]
and he's like yeah but he's like I was
saving so much money over so he's like
at a grocery store yeah dud with like
the locals and stuff yeah he's hanging
out like next to a Jamba Juice like in
like a food court area like where you
could you could just do that in Southern
California you don't have to be in
[__] Bali dude it's just way hotter
there too by the way so he's like
cooking out there it's like 117° and
he's like cooking in the [__] like
middle of a of a he's just doubling down
on the savings dude it's unbelievable
like that but from $5 to one is is I
mean come on come on how much yeah you
live like a king over there you spend on
a typical like let's say like 3 or 4 day
trip in B like Allin whole thing [__]
dude what's the average I'd be shocked
if you get over if you get over 500
bucks shut up 500 bucks the food out
there too is cheap it's that cheap dude
I took my whole family out in Bali to go
for breakfast it was like 12 dude was
like everybody was eating [__]
whatever the [__] they wanted right
multiple drinks multiple plates the
whole thing came out to $80 us for 12
people 12 people for 12 people and like
kind of eating like kings yo dude that's
how much I spent on my king crab market
price at Boiling yesterday yeah that
that's your Postmates dude that's your
Postmates for McDonald's $80 should we
just move to Asia let's go to Bali dude
we got to sell a thing of cocaine first
Vietnam was such a good deal oh yeah
Vietnam is another I brought two G there
and I came home with like two G's how
much is a bowl of f how much is a bowl
of like made money in Vietnam two bucks
and that to them is like inflation wow I
get [__] every day of Vietnam my friend
was complaining he's like man did you
know it used to be a dollar and I'm like
you make like 300 Grand a year why are
you complaining that it's a $2 bowl of f
because it was a0 50 c change dude
that's huge a dollar hey that's how rich
people keep their money that's true he
doesn't buy coffee that's why we're poor
also that's how he's been there since
2009 so I think he thinks he's a local
and I'm like why you tripping like it's
a dollar difference dude 14 years in
Vietnam is a big change cuz they had
such a crazy change over the last 10
years though so it probably does he was
like there was no Skys stop defending
Joe's friend so much stop getting on me
so much Joe's friend sucks talking about
TK we're not we're not on Joe's friend
side yeah we're on Jo side what team are
you on bro we're we're riding with him
we have a tattoo with him not with his
friend
[Music]